hi everyone it's Jerry I have a nice
game to share with you from the 1998
Dortmund tournament on the white end
Vladimir kramnik and he's playing
against Peter schidler
okay this is an excellent model game
against the grunfeld defense I think we
can file this one under the technical
knockout category
not a whole lot of tactics very simple
accurate play by kramnik
and if you happen to be looking for a
good game that demonstrates
the strength of a central majority
I think this is one to have a look at
more than once
we really do get to see the role these
pawns play as they roll
now the setup here for white Bishop goes
on its most active diagonal and the
Knight is thrown on rank two
avoiding any irritating pin
attacking defensive D4 and now the
immediate exchange of C pawns so that
The Black Queen could insert the check
counter attack
Queen goes back home the offer of a draw
in a way
of course if the bishop goes here we
could be repeating moves white of course
wants more and says so with D5
best move here is 95. that's what black
plays
if you capture The Rook that's a good
way to lose
there'd now be two threats and you can't
Parry both
so 95 straight away
don't have to react here is white to
this threat
there's now a pin a protected piece
there
okay this would not be a good capture
exchanging a light Square Bishop for the
dark Square Bishop no way
can't give up that fiend cut out Bishop
but after castles this is now a threat
this is where white reacts
Queen B6 is the follow-up and now
one of those don't try this at home type
moves or you better know what you're
doing if you're going to play this next
move
kramna could simply Castle here fine
move but he's going for more this is
where we see the pawns roll
f4 on board
before you play that move you have to
have a reply you have to know what
you're doing after Knight G4 the move
played in the game
the queen is looking to sweep in now
White's move Bishop D4 this is where
black now goes wrong
what is considered best is to exchange
Bishops
and queens and then put an emphasis on
this idea here challenging White's most
invasive Pawn
you'll notice in this very position
where the white king is on rank one
there are a couple sensitive points in
in White's camp
and that is the night I'm being
unprotected this is tactically there
based on the unprotected Knight and also
this guy here so right around the corner
there's Knight F6 increasing the
pressure
on these two points
it would be nice if this King was a
little bit closer on one of these two
squares so that he can secure these two
sensitive points
compare that with what happens in the
game black inserts this check
white blocks and we get the exchange of
queens and now this King arrives on rank
two he is now only a blink away from
securing these two sensitive squares
the follow-up here is E5
white is winning in this position but
with only one move
important middle game position I wonder
if you can spot what the only winning
move is
feel free to pause the video and see
what you come up with
okay only move that wins
move played in the game H3
now
what's going on here there is a fight
going on over the E5 Square
after E5 what are some things we could
know we could say that this guy is past
connected and passed so maybe we don't
want to give that guy up so easily so if
you're considering capturing on poisson
we're giving up a very big Pawn with
that Exchange
also if you're capturing on E5 you'd be
giving up a very big Square to this
Knight
white does not want to give up control
over that F4 Square so easily
so he gives this Knight a kick
and now where do you go in the game
black captures the bishop
what other options are there if you
react this guy falls
and this is completely winning for white
what are you doing about this threat
you defend with the bishop it's
undermined with G4 the only other way to
defend the Knight on e4 is to play F5
but that would give white two past Pawns
and if you move the Knight well he's
dead after H4
so really can't move the Knight you just
have to go in for this sequence Pawn
takes Bishop Pawn takes Knight
and in this position if black tries D3
might seem appealing but there's a
convenient defense the Knight would be
able to play to C3 and block
and scoop up this Pawn shortly
thereafter
in the game though black goes with G5 so
this is the first
moment where black is on move and he has
the unopposed dark Square Bishop what is
G5 looking to do break down the color
complex where white is most sensitive
the dark squares he wants this to become
a whole
white says no
I will secure F4 I will maintain control
over E5
now the G Pawn is picked up
in comes E5 so look at the material
count here
the white is down upon
but
you know frequently in end games there's
a term that's thrown around or a couple
terms active and passive
frequently those terms are
used to describe Rooks but we can apply
them here to the king positions they're
very active versus passive
black king there is value in this there
is like a hidden Pawn
in this white king because of its
activity
now there's already the threat to when
the material back and look at these guys
monsters
what black plays here Bishop takes
Knight what other tries are there black
goes for Bishop takes Knight we go into
this opposite color Bishop position what
other tries are there here can black be
successful breaking down this
structure here the one that restricts
the unopposed bishop
it's not there I had a look at F6 that's
not working because of discovered check
followed up with E6 you cannot allow
this as black
okay anything else this is the only
other way
H5
and then H4
that's not working either after H4 is in
there you can take on H4
and then take advantage of the G file
something like this pivoting here
looking to double maybe go here maybe go
there completely winning position for
white
so in the game it's Bishop takes Knight
opposite color Bishop position
black has an eye on the C3 Square
this move here aggressive and also
defensive after Rook C3 this is White's
way to maintain this Pawn to maintain F4
to maintain E5 white continues to
restrict the bishop
black doubles
in comes D6 only two steps away now from
queening beautiful
uh Pawn chain here and an excellent
open diagonal for the bishop now
in comes B5 Rook takes Rook very simple
play you cannot recapture with the Rook
if you recapture with the Rook there's
D7 these guys cannot stop d8 equals
Quinn
so you have to recapture with the pawn
and now this guy is ready to do
something
they're both on light squares and
there's a trick after E6 you cannot take
there would be a fork
so
we essentially now have connected past
Pawns they cannot be stopped in the game
it's King f8
is there some other try if the bishop
goes here we're still pushing and next
there's this idea of Bishop here Bishop
there and promotion no good way to deal
with that
in the game it's King f8
E7 check King E8 and one final shot here
a 30 move game
Bishop takes F7 check
black resigns
look at this position what do you do if
you move the king we're going to have
promotion White's going to win The
Exchange and if you take the bishop
if you thought two past Pawns of the
sixth rank were very good look at these
Central pawns you can now not stop
light from cleaning threatening to take
the Rook or even
push
completely winning
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
foreign